[Music]
nevada is seeing a covit 19 surge
right now and state leaders want
everyone to take those numbers seriously
we do thank you for joining us tonight
at five i'm bryan loftis
and i'm denise valdez the governor of
fact just wrapping up that press
conference with a plea to nevadans
orkomana joining us now live from the
grant sawyer state office building with
more on what the governor had to say
orca well denise and brian governor
sislek is making it clear
now is not the time to let up on covet
19 prevention measures like wearing a
mask
and practicing social distancing that's
because we are seeing a false surge of
the virus
here in nevada now the governor says
that we are starting to see
an alarming trend in the number of
coronavirus cases and hospitalizations
across
the silver state according to the white
house covet 19 report
we are in the red zone for cases for the
most recent seven day period
we're seeing roughly 666 new cases a day
double what we saw at the beginning of
september additionally our 14-day test
positivity rate is 9.1 percent
for perspective the world health
organization says communities should aim
for a 5 percent positivity rate
while governor sisalak says his goal is
to continue reopening the state
what happens next is up to us i don't
want to get to that point
and every single nevadan can make a
difference on us getting to that point
or not
the behavior of each and every one of us
can make the difference of whether or
not we're going to trigger that
enforce more restrictions and i don't
want to see that happen so we're working
in
to loosen things up more and get people
back to
what their new normal is full confidence
governor systec also mentioned that he
has been having conversations with state
education leaders as well as ccsd
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
about what reopening schools could look
like the governor saying his goal is for
students to return to the classroom soon
but in order to do that the governor
mentions that we all need to
make sure that we fight against that
coveted fatigue that he was talking
about earlier
and also he says with flu season coming
up and hospitalizations going up
it's very crucial for everyone to take
these these numbers seriously
and get their flu shot reporting live in
las vegas tonight orca mana 8 news now
or